let's now explore an example of a force
in which the work done
it is not path independent and the
classic example is the friction force so
let's consider the following setup
suppose we have a horizontal surface
with friction and we have an object and
we're moving this object so let's choose
an origin we'll call this plus X or I
have Direction it's all going to be
one-dimensional motion and we're going
to move this object from an initial to a
final state and we're going to move it
directly in a straight line from the
initial to the final state and this will
be our path 1 and in our second case
what we'd like to contrast with that is
that we like to move the object out to a
point X a and then back to the final
point so this is our path 2 has two legs
and we'd like to compare the work done
on these two paths
so for path 1 we'll begin by calculating
our force here is the kinetic friction
force and the kinetic friction force
remember is in this case it's going to
oppose the motion so we have force
kinetic for path 1 and that is minus mu
K mg in the I hat direction
and so when we do the integral for the
work from X initial 2x final this is
path 1 then we have minus mu K mg I hat
dotted into now what is the DS for this
path it's simply DX i hat so DX I had
notice we're not putting any sign into
DX that's the sign will show up in terms
of our endpoints of our integral so when
we do the dot product here we have I had
AI hat that's 1 and so this integral we
can pull out all the constants Miu K mg
we're just integrating DX from X initial
to X final and so we get mu K
mg times X final minus X initial now for
path 2 we have two separate integrals so
for path - we'll just show the first
part where we're going from X initial to
XA then the friction force is opposing
the motion and we always just write the
X in terms of the coordinate system DX I
have because you'll see that the signs
show up in the endpoints of the integral
and then when we're coming back I'll put
that in a different color and I'll put
it below it so when we come back
notice the friction force is going to
change direction D s will still be
written that way but pay close attention
to the endpoints of the interval so now
what we have is two intervals so W is
the integral from X initial to XA and
now I'm going to take the dot products
here directly it's the same friction
force we still have this same integral
which is minus mu K mg DX now here's
where it's a little bit tricky notice on
this path FK is plus mu K mg I hat and
so when we dotted into D X we have a
plus sign we'll just continue that
integration here of mu K mg DX from X a
2x final both of these integrals are
straightforward integrals to do this is
minus mu K mg X a minus X initial and
over here we have a plus mu K mg X final
minus X initial notice X final minus X X
a rather is negative and so both of
these integrals are negative as we
expect and so what we see here is that
we have two pieces so minus 2 mu K and
G XA and then we have that other piece
mu K mg X final minus X initial hang on
there's a this is actually a plus sign
so our answer is very different because
the displace the amount that we've
traveled is different so what we see
here is an example of a force which is
the work done is not path independent
but depends on the path taken from the
initial to the final States